[Musica]
vorrei raccontarvi tre storie lui e
filippo e amministratore delegato di una
piccola società del settore
metalmeccanico da poco uno dei suoi
manager storici ha lasciato l'azienda
per andare a fare l'amministratore
delegato di un'altra società
filippo deve scegliere chi mettere al
suo posto e molto indeciso andrea 33
anni potrebbe essere la persona giusta è
in azienda da otto anni e in questo
periodo di tempo ha dato grandi prove di
capacità di gestire le squadre
competenze ha portato competenze
innovative digitali in azienda ha una
spiccata leadership però filippo si
chiede come la prenderebbero gli altri
sarebbe l'unico di dieci anni più
giovane rispetto a tutti i suoi colleghi
e si chiede se forse non è un po
rischioso fargli fare un passo così
grande e così giovane nella sua carriera
in una posizione di così grande
responsabilità visibilità
chissà forse potrebbe provare a
bruciarsi
e allora pensa che forse per questa
posizione è meglio prendere una persona
più matura in termini di età ed
esperienza
dopo sei mesi andrea lascia l'azienda
per andare a lavorare da un competitor
esattamente coprendo la stessa posizione
e dà prova di grandi capacità in italia
i manager under 35 sono il 4 per cento
marta lavora da un po di anni in una
grande azienda del settore beauty le
hanno dato da poco un incarico di
responsabilità ed è rientrata da due
mesi dalla maternità a un bimbo di sei
mesi è molto contenta però certo è un po
affaticata
in questo periodo il suo capo luigi la
sempre stimata moltissimo come anche i
suoi colleghi è però la osserva in
questo momento è la vede così stanca e
si dispiace ripensa a sua moglie quando
avuto hanno avuto il primo bambino a
quanto era presa quanto era affaticata e
quindi decide di comunicarle che per
lasciarla più tranquilla sposterà il
progetto su un altro collega per marta
questo è un colpo durissimo
lei percepisce di non essere più in
grado di stare di dare lo stesso valore
all'azienda che dava prima e si chiede e
pensa che forse non è possibile essere
una brava mamma è una brava
professionista pensa che dovrà fare
presto una scelta in italia poco più di
un terzo delle donne tra i 25 ei 35 anni
con due figli lavora
alberto è papà di due bambini sono due
bambini meravigliosi belli intelligenti
lui è anche un padre molto presente gli
piace stare insieme a loro giocare
raccontarli storie e poi si ritiene
particolarmente fortunato perché sono
molto bravi a scuola quindi non deve
stargli troppo dietro
in particolare tommaso è bravissimo
non si sa come perché non l'ha mai visto
studiare però vabbè l'importante sono i
risultati
carlotta
lei è la più piccola anche lei è molto
brava sempre precisa fa i compiti per
prima certo italiano è decisamente la
sua materia preferita matematica insomma
diciamo che non è che proprio sia
portata tant'è che alberto pensa ma
forse potrei presentarle quel mio amico
professore di matematica molto simpatico
che potrebbe farla appassionare alla
materia potrebbe essere un'idea
poi però dice ma no in fondo è normale
alle bambine piacciono di più le materie
letterarie anche per sua sorella quando
erano piccoli era così in italia più di
un terzo dei genitori pensa che i maschi
siano più bravi in matematica che cosa
hanno in comune queste storie sono tutte
storie dove inconsapevolmente è stata
persa un'opportunità
sono tutte storie dove le decisioni non
hanno massimizzato il risultato e sono
tutte storie dove nessuno voleva nuocere
a qualcun altro
sono tutte storie che nascondono dei
byas guardate questo numero
mi sapete dire se è pari o dispari ecco
pari
in realtà per essere proprio certi
secondo i principi della matematica
avreste dovuto fare una divisione
dividerlo per due e vedere se c'era o
non c'era il resto operazione un po
lunga da fare in questo momento vi
ricordate alle divisioni alle elementari
ecco immagino che molti di voi forse
neanche hanno letto tutto il numero per
intero sono andati soltanto a vedere
l'ultima cifra in fondo a destra e
controllare sera pari perché sappiamo
che in questo modo vuol dire che appare
tutto il numero
questa è una scorciatoia mentale molto
utile perché ci permette di prendere una
decisione
in poco tempo e senza usare troppi senza
fare troppi sforzi cognitivi le
scorciatoie mentali se le costruiamo nel
corso della nostra vita
inconsapevolmente e sono frutto di
un'evoluzione nel tempo
viviamo in un mondo molto complesso la
nostra mente riceve continuamente una
grande quantità di dati informazioni e
per sopravvivere
abbiamo bisogno necessariamente di
saperli elaborare molto velocemente e
prendere decisioni altrettanto
velocemente decisioni molto semplici
come quando siete entrati questa mattina
nella sala avete scelto dove sedervi ma
anche decisioni più complesse come
quelle che riguardano le persone con cui
abbiamo a che fare quotidianamente
queste scorciatoie le costruiamo nel
corso della vita e si chiamano
euristiche ci permettono di prendere
decisioni velocemente senza dover tutte
le volte pesare valutare analizzare ogni
dettaglio alcune di queste scorciatoie
però sono delle stradine pericolose che
ci portano apre a fare delle valutazioni
sbagliate non corrette si chiamano byas
quindi i by us sono delle particolari
euristiche usate per esprimere dei
giudizi che alla lunga diventano
pregiudizi su cose mai viste o di cui
non si è mai avuto esperienza esistono
molte tipologie di byas ma oggi con voi
ne voglio condividere 2 experience byas
tutti noi siamo portati a pensare che la
nostra interpretazione di un fatto di un
evento o il nostro punto di vista sia
quello corretto è una cosa naturale
se pensiamo alle storie che vi ho
raccontato luigi
il capo di marta ha dato per scontato
che marta si sentisse e pensasse
esattamente come si pensava come pensava
sua moglie e quando avuto il primo
figlio alberto il papa ha dato per
scontato anche carlotta non potesse
essere appassionata alla matematica
perché è una bambina e perché così era
stato per sua sorella quando erano
piccoli
in realtà le ricerche ad oggi ci hanno
ampiamente dimostrato che il cervello
della donna il cervello dell'uomo hanno
esattamente le stesse capacità
matematiche l'altro bajos è il distance
byas noi esseri umani siamo pigri
abbiamo una preferenza per tutto ciò che
è più vicino nello spazio e nel tempo
mentre evitiamo tutto ciò che è lontano
se pensiamo ad esempio di filippo
l'amministratore delegato lui ha scelto
la soluzione più semplice mettere in
quella posizione una persona di
comprovata maturità ed esperienza
forse se avesse dedicato più tempo alla
decisione avrebbe valutato meglio il
potenziale di andrea e forse avrebbe
deciso per esempio di affiancargli un
coach
nel primo periodo o essere lui di
supporto nel caso in cui avesse avuto
qualche difficoltà all'inizio come
possiamo fare per difenderci dai by us
per prima cosa dobbiamo accettare che
siamo tutti vittime di by us è la
neuroscienza dircelo sì proprio tutti
certo è molto più facile a dirsi che a
farsi ovviamente perché noi esseri umani
oltre ad essere pigri siamo anche molto
narcisisti tutte le volte che
ammettiamo di aver sbagliato di essere
in torto si attivano delle aree nel
nostro cervello che ci fanno provare
delle emozioni negative mentre quando
abbiamo ragione
siamo contenti siamo felici si attivano
delle aree che ci fanno provare delle
emozioni positive
e la cosa divertente è che questo
avviene sia quando abbiamo davvero
ragione sia quando ci raccontiamo di
avere ragione anche se i dati dimostrano
qualcosa di diverso
quindi la nostra mente naturalmente a
una scorciatoia che va a selezionare
tutti quei dati e quelle informazioni
che confermano le nostre credenze
per esempio se pensate se avete pensato
nella vostra vita che in effetti i
maschi sono più bravi in matematica
delle femmine
avrete memorizzato e osservato tutte
quelle situazioni in cui questo si è
verificato per confermare la credenza
quindi cosa possiamo fare prendere atto
del fatto che l'intelligenza
l'esperienza e la conoscenza non ci
rende meno suscettibile a byas più
conosciamo un argomento più ci sentiamo
sicuri meno abbiamo voglia di metterlo
in dubbio
e quindi creiamo una barriera con valore
di in questi anni abbiamo lavorato molto
su questo tema e abbiamo individuato
tante soluzioni organizzative
individuali per lavorarci
oggi però con voi vorrei condividerne 3
che potete portarvi a casa nella vostra
vita di tutti i giorni
la prima prova a fare lo iato test
implicit association test è un test che
si trova su internet e serve per far
emergere le connessioni automatiche che
avete con alcune parole per esempio
maschi e femmine
la maggior parte di noi hanno una
connessione più forte tra maschi e
scienza come parole e tra femmine e arte
oppure magri e grassi la maggior parte
di noi ha una preferenza automatica per
i magri diventa un cacciatore di by us è
molto difficile lavorare su noi stessi
quindi possiamo andare a cercare i byas
negli anni
quello siamo bravissimi mettetevi a
disposizione di amici colleghi parenti
per aiutarli a trovare quelli che sono i
loro schemi mentali quelli da cui devono
uscire e denunciate tra virgolette
quando vedete che il qualcuno non è
valorizzato a sufficienza a causa di un
bayern
altra cosa
quando dovete prendere delle decisioni
su qualcuno fatevi aiutare da una terza
persona
chiedetegli di mettervi alla prova di
fare emergere tutti i buyout che voi
potreste avere in quella situazione e
insieme andate a cercare quei dati e
quelle informazioni che mettono in
dubbio le vostre credenze
in questo modo potrete essere un po più
sicuri di prendere davvero la decisione
migliore è molto faticoso
come vedete lavorare sui paia se vi
richiede anche tempo per questo motivo
non potete farlo più tutto su tutto però
cercate quelle volte che dovete prendere
decisioni cruciali su un'altra persona
di farvi la domanda come sarebbero
potute andare a finire diversamente
le nostre storie andrea sarebbe stato
promosso
sicuramente la sua azienda non avrebbe
perso un talento che aveva coltivato per
otto anni e che ha portato il suo know
how ma anche la sua innovazione presso
un competitor
se luigi avesse chiesto a marta come si
sentiva lei avrebbe risposto che si era
molto stanca però era anche contenta di
seguire quel progetto e si stava
organizzando un suo marito per gestire
diversamente la sua vita da neo mamma e
papà alberto avesse presentato il suo
amico professore a carlotta lei avrebbe
potuto valutare liberamente se era o non
era davvero interessata alla matematica
e quindi fare delle scelte più libererà
grandi su che cosa studiare
lei però è piccola quindi forse
incontrerà qualcuno che le darà questa
possibilità
ho scelto di raccontarvi delle storie
semplici quotidiane che possono capitare
tutti i giorni non delle struggenti
storie di discriminazione anche dietro a
quelle ci sono gli unconscious byas ma
sono partita di e qui perché sono
convinta che è da queste piccole cose
che possiamo portare il cambiamento se
ognuno di noi nelle sue decisioni si fa
quella domanda in più può cominciare
davvero a far emergere il talento
profondo delle persone che vi circondano
ea costruire un mondo più meritocratico
[Applauso]